The battle for Anaxes
one of the Republic's
largest shipyards is under
attack from Admiral Trench's separatist
forces
Jedi generals Mace Windu and
Anakin Skywalker lead a two-pronged
assault on the ground and in the air
but after weeks of heated battle and
mounting losses the republic's grip on Anaxes
begins to slip away
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my Star Wars the Clone Wars
season 7 episode 1 video Clone Wars has
saved everyone give your biggest hello
there because they're all back so we'll
break everything down if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos there's going to  be 12
episodes total in season 7 will do top
10 and Easter eggs as we go along
obviously spoiler warning if you have
not seen the episode yet starting with
number 10 the origin of the episode so
the bad batch this episode was
originally planned to be the first
episode of season 7 way back when they
were still making season 6 they had to
stop production halfway through because
Disney cancelled the Clone Wars when
they bought Lucasfilm and Star Wars from
George Lucas back in 2012 the reason why
Disney cancelled Clone Wars was because
of their contract with Cartoon Network
Cartoon Network is owned by Warner
Brothers and Disney wanted a Star Wars
animated series on the Disney Channel or
Disney XD that's where Star Wars rebels
came from but as you can see from the
animation quality on this episode the
quality of the Clone Wars animation was
vastly superior to Star Wars rebels so
obviously fans got really pissed off
when that happened they aired the entire
unfinished arc of bad batch episodes
from season seven at Star Wars
Celebration in 2015 they even uploaded
the episodes to Star Wars calm but since
then the links have broken so I guess
they took the episodes down because they
finished them for Disney Plus but number
nine all the Revenge of the Sith
Easter eggs so as you probably saw
during the Clone Wars season 7 trailer
there are a lot of big Easter eggs from
Star Wars Episode three Revenge of the
Sith in terms of where these new
episodes take place in the timeline
there are only about three years between
Episode two attack of the clones in
Episode three Revenge of the Sith so the
Clone Wars series takes place in this
really small window of years so of
course there's going to be some overlap
really good example this is where you
see the Clone Wars Season 7 trailer
scene with Anakin talking to a hologram
of Padme who is super pregnant and
unless he's just super dumb which he's
not in this scene he probably knows
she's pregnant with Luke and Leia but
Anakin Skywalker didn't find out that
Padme was pregnant until he returned
from killing Count Dooku in savouring
Emperor Palpatine from general
Grievous's ship at the beginning of her
Venn
so as you probably guessed the Clone
Wars Season seven episodes that do
overlap with the events of Revenge of
the Sith won't break the pre-existing
continuity established by the movies but
you will see some scenes from Revenge of
the Sith happening during the Clone Wars
episodes really good example of this is
order 66 because the main stars of the
Clone Wars in addition to ahsoka Anakin
Skywalker obi-wan Kenobi Darth Maul are
the clones themselves like Rex and Cody
during this episode one so the new Clone
Wars episodes are just going to add a lot
more context for what was going on and
why things happened during Revenge of
the Sith is the same way that the plot
of Star Wars rogue one makes Star Wars
Episode four a new hope better after the
fact like why did the Death Star have
this weird critical weakness built into
it
seems like a pretty big design flaw for
something so expensive and complex oh no
it was because he did it on purpose
during rogue one as a way to sabotage
the empire from within now it makes more
sense so that's kind of what they're
doing with these new Revenge of the Sith
clone wars season 7 episodes so number 8
where is ahsoka tano why isn't she
with the Jedi if you haven't watched the
Clone Wars in a long time ahsoka tano
became really disillusioned with the
jedi and eventually turned in her
Padawan braid to Anakin her master
Anakin Skywalker leaving the order
officially she obviously comes back
during the season 7 trailer this is
meant to be the culmination of her art
during this part of her life but all
that stuff is happening during the siege
of Mandalore that's happening later this
season so ahsoka is really big this
season but she also shows up earlier in
the season going down to level 1313 on
Coruscant to meet someone yes a lot of
you will remember that ahsoka did show
up later in the timeline is a much older
version of the character after the
events of Return of the Jedi
during the Star Wars rebels post-credit
scene she in the Mandalorian is Sabine
Wren were going to the Unknown Regions
to look for Ezra Bridger who had
disappeared earlier in the series before
this huge time jump that's the last we
heard from ahsoka tano until Star Wars
Episode nine rise of Skywalker there was
a big controversy in the fandom when the
movies were released because she showed
up at the end of that movie when Rey was
fighting Emperor Palpatine and she
started to hear all the voices of a
bunch of dead Jedi telling her to rally
ahsoka tano voice could be heard
speaking to Rey but everyone assumed
that meant
sokka had died at some point because it
was all dead Jedi that were speaking to
her from beyond the grave after the
movie came out Dave Filoni posted this
to his Instagram claiming the reports of
a sokka's death were premature implying
that she's still alive during the events
of the new trilogy she'd be around Han
Solo's age somewhere in her 70s so she'd
still be pretty old but not that old but
that also tangentially means that she's
alive during the events of the
Mandalorian episodes so a lot of people
are feeling that there's a strong chance
that a live-action version of ahsoka
will show up at some point on the
Mandalorian number seven the
Mandalorian and Clone Wars crossover
Easter eggs so when the Mandalorian
season one episodes were airing back in
December Jon Favreau and Dave Filoni
explained that some of the events
referenced during the Mandalorian
episodes from the Mandalorian main
characters past would be featured during
the Clone Wars season seven episodes one
of the big things was the siege of
Mandalore which is obviously all this
ahsoka tano versus Darth Maul stuff
that's happening during the trailer that
also includes the Great Purge in the
Mandalorian being rescued by the Death
Watch Mandalorians from Clone Wars and
taken back to Mandalore to train to
become a Mandalorian himself so while
the Clone Wars is happening during this
part of the timeline the Mandalorian
character Din  Djarin is around eight to
ten years old Moff gideon who he also
met during the Mandalorian also reveals
that he has the darksaber which is
probably the bigger point of interest
and he was on Mandalore during that
period of the Clone Wars so if we see
any of those easter eggs when we get to
those episodes I'll start pointing them
out but there are 12 episodes total in
season seven so it'll run for 12 weeks
number 6 the Battle of an axis in the
Republic base so episode one picks up
during the middle of this battle of an
axis during the Clone Wars the planet
itself though was obliterated by a
quote-unquote unknown cataclysmic
disaster after the events of the Clone
Wars right now it's just an asteroid
belt so early theory thinking about
Revenge of the Sith moments if we start
to see them testing the super laser on
the first Death Star this season that
might be the cause of the unknown
disaster that just completely
obliterates this part of space what
other quote-unquote unknown cataclysmic
disasters could make a planet look like
an asteroid belt just like Alderaan it
just seems like there are a lot of
familiar things that are showing up
during these episodes
Toad's Dave baloney was pretty tight
with the details on how Revenge of the
Sith crossover episodes would work but
at the end of Revenge of the Sith the
first Death Star was well into its
construction so early versions of the
super laser technology would have been
in testing for a long time before this
you remember that we actually saw them
finishing construction on the Death Star
during rogue one number five Admiral
trench the main villain of this new Ark
so the last we saw of Admiral trench he
had been thought dead after a group of
Jedi and republic forces took down his
flagship that was back during season two
of the Clone Wars I think with any
resurfaced with a lot of cybernetic
replacement parts keeping him alive
Darth Vader style so there's a lot of
Darth Vader Easter eggs happening during
this first arc with Anakin Skywalker
versus Admiral trench but based on the
early season 7 trailer footage early
prediction it seems like Anakin
Skywalker eventually winds up killing
him in sort of a continuation down the
path of his journey to the dark side
becoming Darth Vader like this moment
here seems like it's happening before he
kills Count Dooku during Revenge of the
Sith and that's just the next step on
the path and you look at the way he's
holding his lightsaber the way he
ignites it the way they framed this shot
is meant to foreshadow this shot of him
igniting his lightsaber to kill all the
Jedi younglings after he's been anointed
Darth Vader by Emperor Palpatine number
4 Captain Rex Cody in order 66 so
Rex and Cody obviously big characters
during this art but we know that Rex
survives to grow old and shows up on
Star Wars rebels Cody we last saw during
Revenge of the Sith firing on obi-wan
Kenobi after Emperor Palpatine activated
order 66 that triggered all the clones
biochips overriding their higher brain
functions forcing them to kill all the
Jedi in the area wherever they were
during the war so we know the tragic
story where cody has headed this season
but the reason why Rex didn't rebel
against the Jedi we know is because he
was able to remove his bio chip so when
order 66 happened he didn't turn on the
Jedi and was able to escape part of this
new bad batch arc of episodes is also
the revelation that their former squad
mate Ecco is still alive and being used
by the separatists Ecco was one of the
first clones who started to realize the
truth about order 66 in how they were
all secretly being programmed to kill
the Jedi number 3 WT
welcome back Echo so during the episode
Rex and Cody hear a transmission from
sky co miner the voice sounds like echos
and is only repeating the line C T 1 4
0 9 which was echos callsign so part of
the rest of this bad batch arc of
episodes will probably deal with them
trying to rescue him from the
separatists he's currently being held on
Skako MInor by the techno Union these
characters based on the events of
episode 1 it's believed that the
separatists have somehow hacked his
brain and are using it to discern the
Republic battle plans and secret
techniques Rick's and Cody found out
during the episode because the
separatists are anticipating moves that
only echo could have known so they just
feel like he's still alive and obviously
they confirmed that at the end of the
episode but number two the bad batch
clone force 99 fighting scenes and their
abilities so the actual bad batch squad
is made up of enhanced clones with
special abilities and mutations that
regular clones don't have they give them
special abilities but they also make
them look very different from your
regular clones the design of the hunter
character seems like he's modeled after
Rambo just the way he wears that red
bandana
he has enhanced senses so he can track
almost anything he can even sense
special electromagnetic wave patterns
from great distances crosshair obviously
has enhanced marksmanship sniper
abilities Wrecker has enhanced strength
really enhanced strength in the tech
character has these crazy enhanced brain
functions which just turn him into this
sort of human battle computer savant
they take that an entire squadron of
battle droids to show you how badass
they are but obviously when the platoon
shows up they're like no we can't handle
an entire platoon by ourselves in number
one the Mandalorian Darth Vader in
baby Yoda so as part of the Clone Wars
season sevens starting Star Wars rolled
out all these emojis on social media
pretty standard but there's one secret
emoji for a mystery character that's
supposed to reveal itself later this
season so everyone just heard secret
character special emoji showing up later
this season and everyone's wondering if
it means baby Yoda will be referenced
somehow during the episodes because he's
only a few years younger than Anakin
Skywalker during the events of Clone
Wars or if maybe the secret character is
the Mandalorian himself Din Djarin or
more likely I think it'll be a Darth
Vader tag that they'll create after
Anakin Skywalker is maybe anointed Darth
Vader
by Emperor Palpatine during the events
of Revenge of the Sith when those events
sort of crossover with the Clone Wars
episodes there will still be Mandalorian
episode points of crossover but I think
it's more likely that all the promo
stuff that they're rolling out is
specific to the main characters of the
Clone Wars like Anakin Skywalker ahsoka
tano obi-wan Kenobi let me know if you
spotted any other big Easter eggs during
the episode that I didn't mention in the
video episode 2 will air next week my
video will post next Friday just like
normal so click here for all my
Mandalorian season 2 teaser videos and
click here for my new Spider Man 4
marvel special announcement video thank
you so much for watching everyone stay
awesome
This is the way!